my definition of success
so i got a tweet that came in love you
guys from anthony who wrote in to say
evan how do you define success
for me success is a pretty simple
pretty simple answer it's being happy i
think people who are happy
are successful maybe that's different
than what most people will look at most
people look at
you know how much money you're making
what companies you started
or you know what what job title you have
for me that doesn't it doesn't matter
because you could be the richest person
in the world you could be the most
most successful person i guess in the
world in terms of how much money you
have but if you're not happy if you're
not enjoying what you have
well then in my mind at least you're not
successful the concept of happiness
is is a hard one and we all know what it
feels like to be happy
and some people are way happier than
others nobody's happy all the time
though
nobody is happy all the time you know
those people put on that
or have always been happy they're faking
it some of the time
and you have to understand what is it
that makes you happy i think for
for different people it's different
things so all i can share is what makes
me happy
the three things that make me happy are
freedom growth
and impact so freedom i need to feel
like i'm in control of my own time
when i'm not in control of what i do i
get very frustrated and
upset so that's why it's hard for me to
work for somebody else to have a job
it's hard for me to do things that i
don't like doing
because it makes money i don't i don't
enjoy that stuff i need the freedom
if i want to go off and take half a day
off to go to starbucks and enjoy the
weather outside and have a frappuccino i
can do that if i want to fly to paris
for the weekend just because i can do
that i have the freedom to do that i
need freedom
to be happy growth
i need to feel like i'm i'm learning
constantly
if i'm not learning something new in
some area of my life
i start to get unhappy so sometimes that
comes from within my business maybe it
might be a new video project or i'm
learning a new
online skill or i'm working on my
website or i'm helping somebody out
whatever it is i need to feel like i'm
getting better
sometimes it's in my personal life maybe
i'm learning
a new dance or i'm learning to be a
better dj or i'm doing something with my
family where we're learning together i
need to feel like i'm getting better
and then the third one is impact i need
to feel
like what i'm doing is important i need
to feel like
it's helping people in some way and and
this is different for everybody right
freedom may not be important to you
growth may not be important to you
impact may not be important to you but
this is what makes me happy i need to
feel
like my time on this planet
matters it matters to people i've left
the planet a better place
than when i came here that's important
to me that's why i do a lot of the stuff
that i do
even though it makes zero money i do it
because i love it and because i think
that it's going to have an impact so i
think if you're trying to figure out
what success is i think we're all
we're we're lured by society into this
concept that money equals success or
power equals success
a lot of people fight it you know we
fight that because for
a lot of people that's not their
definition of success
and we're kind of pushed into it by
other people and then you find yourself
doing things you don't like trying to
make money and you're not happy
and so you're not successful so
if you use happiness as a as your
determination for who
is successful or not then focus on the
things that make you happy
focus on the things that make you come
alive that make you feel
strong that make you feel like you're
doing things that are meaningful
that light up your eyes focus on those
things and the more
of those things that you do the more
you'll be successful and feel successful
believe for those of you watching like
the video thumbs up below
leave a comment ask the question below
let me know what your definition of
success is i'd love to see it
and if you want to see more videos like
this click on my face to subscribe to
the channel
thank you so much i'll see you soon